he tells me he's like you know i just
expanded the vision for for what i'm
doing he goes
um
this is eventually going to be the next
blackrock bigger than blackrock i think
i can be a trillionaire in the next 50
years
oh my gosh
[Music]
all right um what's going on
uh not too much dude we um is the last
episode the ryan holiday one
yeah what did you think
i wanted to debrief that real quick
because i thought he was um
really great uh
i said i think i said this maybe i don't
know if it was on air if this was
afterwards
but he um
he felt to me like one of the happier
more calm and peaceful people that we've
ever had on the show
uh he just had this vibe about him like
he wasn't um like a lot of people come
on the show and they try to put on a
show
they are trying to perform or they're
trying to kind of play up something
they're trying to sell you on something
they're trying to
uh present themselves as bigger than
they are and it's not just on the show
this is life and uh or you meet somebody
and they're kind of like you know they
have the disease of more more and more
and i know it because i i have it myself
in many ways where i kind of want uh
you know
more success more whatever um
and i just felt like he was a guy who
was curious about certain things like to
do certain things but didn't have this
like he didn't seem like an itchy person
didn't say there's all these itches all
across his body that he was trying to
scratch he seemed at ease and i thought
that was just like one thing that i
don't know if it comes across on a
podcast because you're listening to it
or you see the guy you don't necessarily
pick that up but that was the one thing
that stood out to me
i think he's really like that i've uh
i've been friendly with them i wouldn't
say we're like close friends but
friendly for a couple years now but
neville and noah are all really good
friends with them and they said that
like he pretty much just stays at home
most of the time and like if you want to
see him you got to drive out to his farm
and like he's a homebody and he like
just knows what he likes and he and he
does it
yeah i thought it was interesting
because his reputation at least for me
in my head right the image i had in my
head was this guy's like this internet
marketer growth hacker which is like
usually one breed of person
right like there's like that comes with
a certain certain package usually and
then
you know we'll have this like kind of
he's an author and then he has like uh
but his books are all about like kind of
interesting things right he doesn't
writing boring normal calm books he's
writing like conspiracy and how the
media is messed up and then like you
know trust me i'm lying right like these
provocative books
and then he had the daily stoic and i
was like oh okay reminded me a little
bit of like you know like tim ferriss i
think is kind of like this where
tim ferriss started off
you know selling brain supplements which
is again like an internet marketer type
of thing you know it comes with a
certain package to create a brain
supplement company uh then second to
that was like an author
and then you know now is like extremely
zen and like into mindfulness and
detoxification and digital detoxing and
moving away from san francisco and you
know was just trying to get away but
like even peop usually when i find
people who are gravitating towards
things like meditation and stoicism and
um you know micro dosing psychedelics
they feel like they're still on the
search for that calmness he felt like he
found the calmness and that was kind of
the distinction
i think i was envious of him for two
reasons the first was he said that he
dropped out of college because he wanted
to be a writer and he is a writer i was
incredibly envious that he had found
what he loved and he found it very early
and he and he actually same thing with
his wife he said he met his wife and he
was 20. they've been dating since they
were 20 or something like that right
this guy found love early
i was envious of that and the second
thing was he did not maybe not envious
but what i learned was he did a really
good job of basically
you know you and i talk about ideas and
all this stuff and we know a lot of
successful people but at the end of the
day once you get past a relatively low
point it's about being happy and he did
a really good job of putting that into
perspective
you know even your addiction i would say
like yeah you know
it's one thing to say it we all say it
it's another thing to actually do it
and uh you know it's like oh so okay you
got this money you made this money doing
this you know you made this money are
you using that to parlay your fame and
whatever into more and more no i like
writing so i keep writing right and it's
like um do you okay you you know you
what do you do with your investments are
you in crypto trying to hit the next big
home run i bought a bookshop it's like
oh [__]
this guy's extremely grounded
so rob dyrdek made one line on our pod
that always kind of stuck with me so
he's like this happy guy but then
i made a comment like yeah i think like
i didn't know that you're gonna be this
big and he goes yeah like i'm on my way
to becoming the billionaire like i
deserve
and i thought it was funny that
he's like he definitely had a chip on
his shoulder and he was like more and
more and more and more and more which
isn't bad that's very human but that was
interesting and i almost felt like ryan
didn't necessarily have that we have a
buddy who texted me yesterday
uh he's
you you you don't know him as well but
uh i think you can mention him
i don't know maybe i shouldn't say his
name because it's a funny funny quote
say it say it and then say his name then
bleep him
texted me and he goes uh you know he
tells me he's like you know i just
expanded the vision for for what i'm
doing he goes um
this is eventually gonna be the next
blackrock bigger than blackrock i think
i can be a trillionaire in the next 50
years
oh my gosh
and i was like
he says it with a straight face he's not
like joking which is uh you know
amazing and delusional and amazing again
right that's like those that's my that's
how my brain goes i'm like wow then i'm
like wow that's delusional then i'm like
well you know
great you know good for you that's what
gets that
capable
is he capable pulling it off yeah like i
i said this early on i met him when he
was like 19 or 20
and i said of all the people i've ever
met if i had to bet my life
which one of these people who today is
worth less than you know five million
dollars will be a billionaire
i would have put my life on the line on
him because i was like he's singularly
focused on just that
so it's like you know michael phelps
woke up every day and swam like for
[__] three hours and then 18 000
calories and then did that for like 12
years straight and didn't take a day off
so it's like yeah when you devote your
life singularly to a pursuit whether
it's swimming laps in a pool or it's
becoming a billionaire
you know that already cuts you away from
99 of the population that wants to be
wealthy but also wants to be
you know in a good relationship it also
wants to be this and also wants to have
fun with their friends and go out on the
weekends it's like he cuts out all that
so you know i think it gives him the
odds on top of being a very smart
capable guy right like he's already
amongst the like high iq people then
within that he's got an obsession on
money that very few people have
let me let me please play devil's
advocate or as my other favorite podcast
calls it devil's avocado let me play let
me play devil's avocado here for a
second who says that so uh michael
bisping said it is all that goes double
doubles avocado
yeah so uh of two things one i'm reading
this book or i already read it called
spor recently called sports gene and
they basically talk about genetics and
they're just like look like the closer
you live to the equator the longer your
limbs are and the shorter your torso is
and that just makes you like 15 percent
better runner and what that means is
like if your legs are longer
that just means that if if we all work
the same and the best people from who
don't have long legs and short torso
some of them definitely can compete but
like you have a fifteen percent edge and
when you're talking about gold medals
and being the best in the world that
fifteen percent is like a world tenth of
seconds on things you know that helps
yeah they're like that that's just so
it's like it's like it's like a giraffe
versus a hippo or you know something
like that like that just matters
and
so one
becoming like a billionaire which is an
outlier like i actually think that like
you can kind of sweat your way to like
maybe 5 or 10 million in a lifetime but
becoming a billionaire and this huge
outlier i think it takes like a
particular type of skill like you just
genetically predisposed to have it in
your favor and i think that matters
you're not saying this kid does or does
not have it but i think that it's more
important than just like training for 12
hours a day i think that just being
gifted genetically is more important
than hard work uh to be the best so you
need both second
you you know like
i all i definitely believe like the
whole pull yourself up by your bootstrap
thing but in order to be like let's just
call the threshold a billion in reality
it's probably like 200 million 100
million like there's so much luck that
needs to be involved on a macro level
it's like which country are you born in
but on a micro level it could be just
like well like did you just me happen to
do do it with your friends
in college you know yeah or are you able
to stay healthy um did you not fall in
love and meet someone like right you
know what i mean like there's all these
tiny like luck things that really matter
like jeff bezos like did his mom i think
wasn't he adopted yeah he's adaptive so
like that is like a
oh
it's a big decision but it's like a
relatively small like decision it's a
yes or no decision that changed
everything totally or did you decide to
go to princeton versus stanford like
it's uh and you know jesus would have
been successful no matter what but
there's a difference between uh this guy
made 10 or 30 million dollars in his
lifetime versus became at one point the
richest man on earth or the richest man
ever to walk the earth or whatever you
know like there was a
the variance so to me success is very
success has success itself and the yes
or no has very little to do with luck
the magnitude of success has a lot to do
with luck but that's why i was saying
you know i'm i'm creating a funny
hypothetical which is of people who
already are not already in a good
position financially like under five
million net worth let's say they're not
they don't have some edge there where
they're just gonna invest their way to
success
um
of those people who haven't already made
it who would i bet is most likely to
make it well
i agree with you that if it was the
field versus him i'd take the field but
uh
what am i going to bet on like for
example i think you could say like our
buddy jack smith i think you could say
you know jack is a quirky curious guy
who's actually not obsessed with money
at all but just like really
into what he's into and it's usually off
the beaten path that's gonna usually win
in a way and he's super smart also right
like they're still in the top one
percent iq or whatever um that's going
to have a good outcome i believe that
but um
but you're kind of betting that this
guy's luckier this his magnitude of
success is gonna he's gonna have more
luck than this guy and i think you could
kind of tell who's gonna get lucky or
who's not
but it's really hard to place it like
who would you bet if i told you that
same situation i don't know if you have
a name but before somebody had
a bunch of money
who in your life did you run into that
you're like all right if i had to say
who's going to become a billionaire in
my life this is who i would pick
i mean when i met moyes ali he didn't he
had sold the company and he probably was
worth less than five million dollars and
immediately took a few days of meeting
him like oh uh you're a shark and what
what was it yeah shark is a good word
what what it was a shark
um
he was had a singular focus i mean he
was customer focused but singular focus
he's like
and
really high intensity very high
intensity singular focuses focused
uncomfortably intensity i'm
uncomfortable protect him
yeah uncomfortable and also he like he
was a lawyer from harvard so like top of
the top at the top yeah and then his
brother is uber successful so i'm like
there's no reason why you should screw
this up and so when i met him that i
thought was hilarious he has these great
one-liners moy said something that was
like um
you know like i don't know some people
were put you see usain bolt and you say
that guy was put on earth to run um you
see this person they were put up michael
phelps you see his body he was put on
earth to swim i was put on earth to do
one thing
increase earnings per share
[Laughter]
he always uh he he
like one time he told me he goes you
know my worst the worst phrase i hate on
earth is when i hear it it makes me
cringe and i run the run the other way
blue chip stocks he goes do you want to
talk about words that i love
uh what did he call it distressed assets
distressed asset
that's what he said he goes he goes the
two most beautiful words of the english
language distressed assets
and he said that i was like oh my god
one time i heard amazing one-liners one
time i heard him
uh one time we met with this person who
has this vitamin company that's doing
really well and he was being really
cordial and nice and everything and just
saying hi and then this person walked
out the room and he looks at me and he
goes that person's business is one
google search away from me ruining it
it's like that's one google search away
from me copying their company because
he's like the formula is nothing and
that was like that was the first line
that he said he is really he's a poet um
all right i've got an idea so
andrew wilkinson texted me because he's
in my str group str stands for
short-term rentals my latest obsession
we'll see if it sticks but very
interested in it and i think we need to
rebrand that by the way way too like std
you know like does anybody know what an
str is no i don't why don't i just say
dorks you know my like real estate or
airbnb you know or whatever vacation
rentals
dude here's the truth i made this group
when i was going to the bathroom and i
just tweeted it out and you'll notice
the picture is just a boot that's just
because i just like googled as like i
googled something you know
like this is a shoe
yeah this is a shoe
i don't remember but that was that
picture was available which goes back to
your uh your point you did a long time
ago that people got really upset with
you we were like
don't think about a name or don't buy a
domain a good domain or something you
said something like that that people got
really pissy about and you were
basically saying
don't let that don't let figuring out
the branding and the name hold you back
from the thing which is like getting it
out there yeah yeah so that's what i did
i like did it like literally when i was
going to the bathroom this was like a
literally a two-minute thing
and it just is what's it called sam's
str crew no i keep wanting to say std
so 1200 or 1500 people you know what i
think i could do i'm not sure if i'm
going to do this but you know what i
think i can do i think i could turn this
into a newsletter business and i think
it could be like a really good business
and i'm going to explain why have you
ever heard of och davis the headphone
daniel ock no
okay so uh look up daniel ock uh i think
he's like probably worth eight or ten
billion dollars so och davis is like a
famous hedge fund this guy like is i
think that um i'm almost positive that
when
elon musk got shorted this guy was one
of the guys and he sent him like a pair
of shorts if i remember correctly and so
it's this billion-dollar multi-billion
dollar maybe 40 billion dollar hedge
fund anyway it got started because the
davis was this guy named ziff davis who
started um
oh sorry his name was bill ziff who
started zif davis publishing company
have you heard of zif davis no
okay so zif davis was a basically at
this point it's still around it has a
five billion dollar market cap it does
over a billion dollars in revenue it's
been around since probably the 60s it's
got it got its start because it owned
magazines in a ton of different super
specific but uh high-end industries so
for example they owned the most popular
magazines on popular popular electronics
sailing flying they own this thing
called mac week they eventually started
ces which or they started um
it was called one thing and then it now
is has become ces
um masasan started cs now masasan bought
it from davis okay and
so he like it was all niche publications
and it's still a business
and i think i could do something like
that for strs where you create an empire
based on like
things that aren't exactly side hustles
but have like serious money going into
them for example this industry probably
isn't big enough but i've been a bunch
of people that have like they've bought
like 10 cars
just for
like toro and
and all that kind of thing
and i've also and so that's kind of
intriguing to me like
i just think that like something can be
done here there's this company called
the penny holder which is sold for like
a hundred plus million dollars and they
basically wrote blog posts on this and
they drove drove traffic to it made
money but anyway i thought that was
interesting and let me tell you one last
thing have you heard of this website
called speed test
speed test like the uh internet speed
test yes yeah of course i go to it all
right
all right that's owned by ziff davis oh
no way so check this out on similar web
it gets a hundred million visits uh a
month in there if you scroll all the way
to the bottom and you click a button
that says advertise that's what you
always want to click for these types of
websites and it tells you all about
their traffic according to their website
it says they get 10 million visits a day
and away the tricks of the trade here on
how you get these numbers i am and so it
says they get 10 it says they get uh uh
i think it says
40 or 50 million monthly uniques but 10
million total visits right now go back
to that home page ben
well i've i always have ad block on so
this is my first time seeing it with ads
dude it's like so there's a button that
says go like test your speed and then
this oh it's like it's like it's like an
army it's like you're surrounded there's
nowhere to go you are gonna look at
these ads there's a mailchimp add up top
and on the right and on the bottom and
on the left there's a ufc
so look at this that's one two three
four five ads right there i don't know
what like the current cpm is on google
but let's just say that all of those
because this is like a relatively high
end potentially market let's say that's
15 per cpm it could be 10 but i bet you
it's between 10 and 15.
on 10 million visits a day that's 50
million dollars a year just on on this
these ads plus go to the top right then
and click where it says developers they
also sell all these solutions so you can
like test the internet speed of i
actually don't know like why anyone
would use this there's a world where
like this is a two or three maybe 200
million dollar your business just from
this simple ass web page
that's wild and there's also i think who
who came out with a competitor i think
netflix did or somebody speed.com
yeah yeah uh yeah somebody came out with
that as well but i think this one's like
pretty entrenched
it's it this would i i looked up if you
like there's some websites that they're
called um
i forget what they're called but ben if
you google speedtest.net or wherever the
url is and then the word revenue there's
all these websites that tell you how
much your traffic is worth and like
they're not really that interesting but
they kind of are
this one it says a billion dollars it
says there this url is worth one billion
dollars
um
like a mobile version of speed tests
like is there an app that just you open
it up it just tells you how fast your
internet is right now and so ios widget
you can just leave that open all the
time great question so i in order to get
all this information i went and read a
lot of z2
zip davis's annual reports and they just
acquired a company that they want to
integrate into this company that does
that for mobile so they're working on it
but clearly there's opportunity here
yeah that's funny um
yeah the thing with speed test is like
any uh it's like they get free customers
because any time somebody like if you
call your comcast or whatever they're
like hey can you go run a speed test go
to speed test and they like send you the
link and so it's like
it's like every troubleshooting it
person like sends you this link so that
they're not like paying for customers
they get it for free that way
which is an interesting which is
interesting but you kind of said two
things so you're so ziff is interesting
but then you were saying what could i do
with str so there's kind of like let's
say three paths there's um default do
nothing there's path two which is okay i
keep this facebook group and i just
actually do the short-term rental which
would be like the equivalent of the alex
hermozy guy or whatever doing
like building out more gyms right so
it's like well you can actually make a
lot of money if you just do the
short-term rentals and just use that
information put your energy there
or you can put your energy towards
building the community and the content
around people who are interested in
short-term rentals and there's clearly
appetite your thing's at like a thousand
members and there's like super valuable
interesting content being shared there
so clearly there's value in either a
paid community or a paid newsletter plus
a paid community or something like that
um how do you think about which one is
like a good thing to do
well
i might do the first one which is do
nothing i didn't create this to build a
business i did it just because people
were reaching out to me i didn't want to
talk to everyone and i needed a way just
to like communicate but
if and maybe if i want to but also maybe
if i never want to i think the way that
you go about this is you do like a
i would do one of two things i would
create either a weekly or a bi-weekly
newsletter that explains the news that
impacts this business and regulations
followed by
i would do what you do which is take
like the five most interesting tweets
from the week of str's and i'll explain
my opinion of them i would do that
and then i would also create a um
a paid tool so i would create the best
sheet so like whenever you like look at
these properties you create like a sheet
that like you put your inputs in yeah
yeah and then and then it would say like
look like a lot of people are current
what we've noticed is that currently
people are getting 20 cash on cash
returns so if above you know do that it
below don't do it and here's like how
your math should look so i think you
could create something like that and and
sell it for maybe three to five hundred
dollars a year and then if you wanted to
you do a higher end thing like ten
thousand dollars for people who already
have three or four airbnbs and it just
you talk to all the experts who have
scaled this up successfully to like 10
and 20 units and done it relatively
hands off and i think you could charge
two to five thousand dollars for that
yeah
yeah i think there's a ton of options um
so yeah i think you you've stumbled into
a very
a very cool niche that you're genuinely
interested in so i think you know it'll
play out how it plays out
it's cool right it's very cool yeah it's
one of one of the more interesting
little things
that uh
that i've kind of seen one of our
friends doing recently
yeah i think it's intriguing i have two
silly ideas for you
so silly idea number one um
so i was looking at so remember the guy
from liquid death came on
and he came on i don't know when that
was maybe like a year ago or less than a
year ago no i think it was like two
years ago and and because i i i wasn't
doing this thing two years well you're
right uh but i still had an office and
uh
and we closed the office a while ago but
he and we were i thought we were late he
had raised like 20 or 30 million dollars
i think the other day he raised like a
hundred or like something crazy so it's
just continued to do super well and uh
and i've just seen a bunch of like kind
of like
different water water beverage companies
by the way did you see this this funny
thing they have this kind of tangent did
you see this uh so austin reef tweeted
out um the guy that guy from morningbrew
he tweeted out uh
you know hey you know the rock is gonna
become a billionaire off of his tequila
did you see this tweet
yeah and then the rock replied so i'll
explain it yeah so he goes rock's gonna
become a billionaire from uh
from this tequila
and um he goes you know ryan who is oh
george clooney george clooney's casa
amigos
was sold for 1.2 billion and was doing
like 170 000 cases the rock is already
doing like uh whatever i don't know it
was like three and a half times that so
uh you know the rock's doing whatever no
public math
ex more uh cases he's going to become a
billionaire off this business
and the rock replies which is kind of
amazing because the rock is one of the
most
um
famous people on social media period
like in the world so pull ben pull that
tweet up um by the way
this ben screen sharing thing uh in the
words of sampar can you say game changer
so make that little bigger and we need a
name you know like powerful young jamie
we need uh you know like powerful mormon
ben we need like some so
some killer nickname for you could you
uh just make the font bigger so i can
see it all right there we go so he goes
so dwayne johnson replies and says uh
the following let's scroll that down
okay cheers austin emoji of a tequila
glass i don't know about that first line
lol but i can speak to part to the parts
to i can speak to the other parts of
this tweet blushing smiley face like the
rock is flirting with him and he goes uh
our projections to one million cases is
pretty mind-boggling and expedient which
i just like when he said expedient i
thought it was so funny
i was like yeah he's right
about a left field and he goes big
exciting big comment exciting taramana
uh announcement coming next week stay
tuned man picture emoji of the earth and
then emoji of a fist brown
which i don't is that the symbol of
tarabana i don't know
uh like i lost it
wait what what were you even talking
about in the first place anyways okay so
i'm talking about
wait let me tell you really quick yeah
austin texted me and he goes hey some
kid that we just hired at the morning
brew said he listened to your podcast
and he said because austin asked this
new guy like all right now who else
should we hire and the kid goes uh
well they're in their employee
onboarding they they say we just hired
you who else should we hire which is
like a guy raises yeah and this kid
raises his hand and goes i listened to
this podcast with this guy named sam
parr i don't know what he does for work
we should hire him
[Laughter]
he goes he seems like a pretty good
podcast podcast host maybe we should
hire him yeah and just the other day
sean got an offer to be or like asked to
interview for the head of digital for
playboy enterprises and i'm getting
offers that morning brew like to be a
staff writer
yeah to be a they want me to be a junior
associate writer at morning brew or i
can uh become hedge digital at playboy
enterprises who comes out on top
uh what's your reaction to the uh to the
job offer what do you think about that
you know like i'll have to talk to my
family
we'll have to talk to my family and i'll
have to see you i'm excited to announce
my next chapter
that's so funny
but um by the way at one point i
remember uh when i was running my
startup this was one of my like
i thought this was fair game all's fair
in love and business but uh but i think
other people would think this is like
completely unethical i told people on my
team i was like oh yeah you should uh go
interview or maybe even just [__] go
work at one of these companies like you
know
while we're building this thing for the
next three months like go just find out
some information about these other
companies that like are like they're not
like our direct competitors but like if
i knew information it would be quite
valuable to me and uh i remember to me i
literally i literally didn't even think
twice about it which is like you know
maybe where my moral compass is broken
but um
i remember and like half of my team was
like oh great idea and then one person
was like you know
i don't know if that's the best idea and
i was like what why what did i say
and then i like realized i was like oh
yeah i guess that could be seen as kind
of like
dirty i guess so you know
i was like oh whoops my bad never mind
if i if i ask you to do anything that is
considered bad cancel uh cancel the ball
well the other tactic is you just um try
to recruit the other people's team not
intending to hire them for a particular
role and you say like super high salary
yeah yeah and they're like well why
would you consider leaving this company
oh you don't like how it's run what what
don't you like about it right i
definitely talked to ex-employees so
i've done this twice i found somebody
who worked at a place before i'll call
them up and usually like somebody who's
like you know left the company they
don't really mind sharing they're not
sharing like confidential information
but like they'll tell you like you know
we thought initially we thought about
things this way but then we learned this
like i i saved i remember once i just
pivoted my business because we were
going to do this one thing and then um
i talked to this guy
and actually it's funny because this
actually played out i was building a
thing that was getting really popular
amongst teens doing group facetime so
this before the iphone let you do groups
and um and so it was like we kind of
started to grow really fast amongst
teenagers and i was like how has nobody
thought of this before this is not like
a new idea just like oh instead of
phrase time group facetime and so i went
back and i talked to the i forgot who
was like there's some app that like had
blown up
seven eight years before that before
house party so we did this and house
party was just starting to do the same
thing
and i wouldn't talk to somebody from
like vauxhall or i forgot what they're
called there's like some app like that
that like you've done this before
and they had gotten pretty far like they
had raised like tens of millions of
dollars they had millions of users they
were like sponsoring concerts that like
teens were going to and be like oh
download our app and then group facetime
yeah group facetime when you go home and
like it was like the thing and it like
didn't work so i asked the guy i was
like hey i'm kind of building group
facetime now like
what went wrong for you guys and he's
like
buddy let me tell you here here's how
your future is going to play out and he
basically described kind of like word
for word a bunch of things and i was i
was like and so in my head i'm thinking
it's good input it's good feedback a
good like real world data
do i in my mind do i have a compelling
counter argument to why my fate is gonna
be different than this person's fate
and i did not and so i was like
yeah i think the things he's saying i
have really no like i think basically
his like main thing was
it'll grow but it won't stick and you'll
never make money and it won't which was
like the whole whole point of the
clubhouse thing yeah which is very
similar to what ended up happening
clubhouse before clubhouse house party
so the guys who created meerkat they
pivoted to house party house party blew
up vcs are funding it tens of millions
of dollars doing group face time and i
remember telling one of the vcs who did
it i go hey here's why we pivoted away
from this like just a couple months ago
even though we kind of had similar like
pretty explosive growth
was i saw some problems with churn i
couldn't think of what i would do to
mitigate it and then i talked to this
guy and he was like yeah here's the
problem
they'll come home from school he's like
he's like there's this there's a sweet
spot in age where
they have friends but they don't have a
car
and so they come home and they're like
trapped so they just want a group
they'll just like go home go to the room
and just call their friend for like six
hours straight he's like let me guess
dude so in your data you're seeing six
hour sessions i was like yeah we are and
he's like yeah cool you that's normal
and i was like oh i thought we were
special he's like no that's exactly how
they'll use this and then they go to car
and then they'll go to college when they
go to college their freshman year
they'll use this ton with their friends
from high school and then they'll never
use it again because they don't they
stop talking to the friends from high
school and then in college their friends
are all around them they don't need
group face time and then they become an
adult they never need group face time
he's like so why why did these get
funded then
uh because you see the chart you see
growth like we were saying you see six
hour sessions and you say uh is this the
next week's social network maybe this is
the next snapchat next tick tock and so
you bet and like sure enough house party
sold for not a lot to
to fortnight basically in the end as
like a team and technology acquisition
and that never saw the light of day
again like it didn't work out um
but you know
i i think other people should do what i
did which was talk to the past
competitors and they're always going to
have like they're always going to be
jaded so you know they're never going to
say this will work because their [__]
didn't work and they think they're smart
but when you hear their argument from
what went wrong you say does that match
my data and experiences and then
secondly do i think anything has changed
is the why now any different um and in
my case it was not
damn
that's crazy man we gotta we gotta like
when i see some of these things get
invested i also get intoxicated into
them as well i'm like oh wait this is
not going to work yeah consumer's just
so hot honestly it's still a fine bet
like somebody was saying this when i did
that clubhouse thing and
a bunch of people were like i think
that's true that i think that's how it's
going to play out
a couple smart people pointed out like
look
um
these guys invested i think they
invested like a hundred million dollars
i think i think andreas invested 100
million dollars at a four billion dollar
valuation for clubhouse at its peak and
like since then the chart just shows it
going down down down but
they're like you know
their fund is this big so this is like
it's not
it's not a it's not a like majority it's
not like they're betting the house on
this they're betting like their normal
size bet it's just a big number to you
secondly
it's a pretty binary option like this is
either gonna go big and this is gonna
this price is gonna look cheaper it's
gonna go to zero
and if it goes to even if it goes down
they're gonna be able to sell this for
something and they have preference so
they're gonna make back you know if this
thing sells for 50 million dollars
eventually to twitter or whoever
um
you know they're going to get the whole
50 because they have like the they get
the money first so they'll make back
their money first and so like
you know like
on the whole it's not that bad of a bet
even if it doesn't work out and if it
does work out you know you're a genius
and great you're you know everything
worked out great so
um
so yeah it was whatever
yeah i was going to tell you an idea
yeah well you're interested in my ideas
are on a beverage company okay so i was
thinking about i was like damn
everybody's done every variation of this
that's like bottled water boxed water
liquid death is water even hand that
looks like a beer logan paul has one
there's vitamin water there's
non-vitamin water there's flavored water
there's sparkling water and then there's
like 10 of each of these right i was
like what what haven't people done
what's the and so i came up with this
brand and this is free for anybody to
run with um just ketchup what's it like
hot dogs put your boys in cut your boys
in uh if you do this
i'm calling it felix falicious um
which is i don't know if you ever read
harry potter but it's basically this
potion that harry gets he wins this
thing and the professor gives him this
potion and it's like you get one drop of
this
and it's it's going to give you great
like good luck for one day 24 hours
you're going to have everything's going
to go your way
and the potion was called felix
felicious or something like that or
felicis i don't know how you say it but
like in my head when i was reading it i
called it felix felicia so we're going
to go with that so
basically it's it's good luck felix
and it's like you're one lucky cat
i don't know
i bet i'm just butchering the
pronunciation and i don't know what it
is but what a great slogan that you just
came up with as we built this brand in
public here it was delicious you're one
lucky cat and um and the you know the
brand it's
basically it's water
that's infused with
things that give you good luck i don't
know what that is it might just be good
vibes it might be like some crystal uh
like you know that goldschlager liquor
like there's like some flakes at the
bottom that are your little good luck
charms um
this comes from you know the himalayas
it comes from whatever the luckiest
place on earth is i don't know what that
is we'll find out
that's the idea it's just placebo water
and it's openly placebo water but you
know what i like when i feel like i had
a little good luck charm at the start of
my day i like the idea that hey you know
i got that big test today if i'm what am
i going to go grab vitamin water or
lucky water i'm gonna go i could grab
the lucky water if i got the test just
in case just in case
i've heard a lot of ideas on this
podcast and that is definitely one of
them
that's that's what i would tell you
about that
my second silly idea is
again another great name it's called
galimony
what's galimony you ask
galimony is alimony for your girlfriend
so here's the deal
let's say you're a girl
you're dating a guy who's super into
crypto right yeah he keeps talking about
ethereum and bitcoin and z cash and the
next big thing he keeps telling you that
3 is the future and you know smart
contracts and the dollar is going to
crash he never needs to talk to a lawyer
again because of smart contracts you say
oh
that's cool actually i have a great
smart contract idea for us and she he's
like oh i'm so glad you're finally
getting into web three this is the
future you're like yeah it's the future
for sure
um hey why don't you just use your
metamask to log into galimoni and what
you do is you put up one either and if
we break up i get half
it's basically a divorce
for non-married couples where the
boyfriend is obsessed with web 3 and
you're the girlfriend and you're like
how do i profit off of this guy's
annoying obsession that's actually
galimoni
smart contract that would go viral and
you just both lock up your you both lock
up your earth or maybe he locks up your
ear he locks up to each and it's
actually actually here's okay let me
make it better
let me just riff with myself here this
is a one-man brainstorm
okay he puts in the eath the eath is
never at risk so because you know maybe
he's like why why would i take this deal
you say the eath is never at risk my
friend
if we break up you'll always get your
eat back but while we're dating this is
gonna be automatically yield farming
interest and i get to keep the interest
on this thing because i'm putting in
this time dating your schmuck ass who's
gonna be obsessed with web3 so
put a little collateral up it's gonna be
farming
we get to have a web3 experience this is
the future am i right that's what i
would be doing if i was dating
so so how does she get paid she like
clicks a button says smart contract
actually maybe it's tied to like your
instagram account i don't know maybe
maybe both sides have to confirm that
you're broken up uh yeah but why would i
ever confirm that because then you start
dating the next girl i'm just gonna send
her this link that says he
signed in with a cryptographic signature
that only he could do with his private
keys saying we are not broken up and so
you know you kind of need that proof of
proof of relationship to be accurate
otherwise you're leaving a little
liability out there by saying
with the utmost true truth that you are
in a relationship so he's gonna have to
he's gonna have to be true have you
heard young kids what they say now is
the receipt
yeah these are receipts yeah like show
me the receipt that's what we're talking
here
i just learned that on that tv show that
you just uh discovered for everyone else
called cheer yeah you know i'm just like
you know such a i'm basically like at
like these indie festivals just finding
these hidden gems like cheer
yeah so galimony i'm on board with i
think that's cool that is a viral idea
ben uh young powerful mormon ben can you
come out here and tell us give me your
rankings 1 to 10 10 being i'm quitting
my job and i'm going starting this one
being i can't believe you just said that
idea give me
felix felicious where are you at
um i'm honestly at like a nine or ten
thank you
thank you you threw out the term though
you just kind of threw away like placebo
water which i also think is like a
separate brand maybe for like science
nerds but like same and the tagline is
like at least we admit we're full of
[__] no no it's it no it's actually
placebo water is actually part of the
category i'm a category creator in
addition to an entrepreneur designer and
fashionista so the category here it's
like plant-based but it'll just be
called placebo-based uh beverages and
these are placebo-based beverages of
which we are you know we launched the
first one
okay and what about i'm on board and
galimony that one
not quite there not not quite to the
level of uh felix felicis i'm gonna say
that's more like a
a six like there's something there but
you need to develop it a little bit more
okay anything less than an eight is a
zero by the way feedback is a gift so i
i thank you for the gift back
can i tell you about one thing really
quick that i just discovered so have you
heard of the twitter handle elon jet
elon jet no what is that dude there's
this young kid who created it's just
basically elon's jet is that the guest
who just tracks elon's jet
and so as of now he's near where our
friend jack lives in hawaii
and so basically when you have how many
followers does this have
eighty-three thousand
and so it's like 20 minutes to the poor
guy who's like trying to produce high
quality content every day and it's
grinding to like 12 000 followers and
then elon's jet just
zips to 83 000 followers overnight
it says something like um
all right took off from honolulu kailua
hawaii now going to austin texas
arriving in six hours and 17 minutes
landed in austin texas approximate time
six hours and 21 minutes
it's pretty pretty wild didn't it um
this
you're not a big sports guy like a
mainstream sports guy but this became a
big deal every year for uh nba free
agency so basically you know kawhi
leonard becomes a free agent he just won
the finals he's the finals mvp he's like
the hottest free agent and nobody knows
where he's gonna where he's gonna sign
and all the reporters were trying to
like work their sources but like their
sources are basically like
teams leaking information that makes
them look good and the agent leaking
information that just like is a
negotiation in public against other
teams and
reddit actually solved the case they
were like hey we can just track kawaii's
jet oh look he's going to la i bet he
signs at the clippers and sure enough
signed with the clippers like wait what
the magic did he have uh like why so i i
how does jet registration work so they
could so they could track basically any
private uh private flight has to go
through air traffic control that's how
these guys do all this stuff so they
have that so what they do is they just
enter they just figure out once what
they don't you don't know who's the
passenger but you figure out whose jet
is it so for example this is elon's jet
what they were tracking for reddit i
think was the owner's jet so they knew
um they knew which owners which teams
were going to pitch him so be like oh a
flight from miami to toronto just left
that's price that's the miami heat
owner's jet so that's them going and
pitching their case oh they got a second
meeting so that means they're doing
better than the next didn't get a second
meeting and they were tracking that and
then i forgot how i think what it was
was like the
someone had let basically like they they
know who the they know who the
billionaire's jets are and you can't
like shake that once that's tagged it's
tagged and so from there they knew and
somebody was like letting him use their
j it wasn't kawhi's jet but like
something like that was going on where a
rich guy was letting kawhi use his jet
for this purposes and so they knew
before the professional journalists knew
where he was going to sign
this is badass i've never heard about
this this is awesome i knew that like
jet tracking was was like that but i
didn't realize it was that good that you
could like for basketball trades right
it's really scary
it's kind of like you shouldn't be able
to do this dude what's crazy is like my
head automatically goes like crazy stuff
like jfk [__] like yeah i'm like oh i
could go kill elon yeah some kidnap or
something like yeah like like
just with a with a good enough shot you
know i got this right
he needs harrison ford flying with him
air force one style if we're gonna put
elon on a jet get off my plane yeah
exactly that was pretty good
wow i'm impressed um all right we're at
the top of the hour i think you got a
jet so uh i gotta go we'll track where
you go on generator yeah right
yeah can someone make one of these for
us and just yeah like do you have one
for southwest yeah just
i'll send you my southwest
anytime flight details i'll just give it
to you and you can just post it
yeah this hurts car rental like like
they put an air tag in my ford taurus
yes sean's still in the burbs he went to
the park
still there
oh chick-fil-a
oh my god it's so stupid
all right we're done
[Music]
you